we're going to discuss making
recommendations without data okay so our
agenda so we're going to firstly talk
about what five tribes is just give you
a little bit of a background so the
problem we're trying to solve then we're
going to go through how making
recommendations is kind of like an easy
and very solved problem and then making
good recommendations is actually the
harder part of our discussion now in
terms of data as data scientists we
often expect data to be available like
you walk into a company but gotta have
data for you but what happens when we
don't have data how do you make
recommendations when you simply don't
have data then we're going to discuss
the deployment and improving kind of
process that we were using and then
we'll go into a Q&A session let's start
with some background what was the
problem we're trying to solve the way we
meet people is random we meet people at
school or university we meet people
where we work we meet people near the
place we live that it shouldn't
necessarily be that way though because
you're very well-connected yeah it's so
hard to meet people with similar
interest let me ask you a question who
here owns a dog no one so if you want
who here it doesn't own a dog see if you
wanted to build to meet people that
didn't own a dog what would be your best
chance you will have to go to each one
of them and ask them do you own a dog or
do you not own a dog
it wouldn't work so our mission in six
tribes was to actually make it easier
for people to meet like-minded people
and to remove the randomness from this
process and make it a little bit easier
the way we did that was by building a
social network that connected you that
was recommending and grouping you around
the people that share the same interests
as you and we did that and we call these
groups tribes so an instance this is an
instance of a tribe and this is a tribe
around people that like to craft things
okay so now let's think about how
recommendations are actually easy to
make so firstly we've got the concepts
of collaborative filtering this has now
been around for like the last ten years
so for example if we take Amazon
let's say you've recently purchased a
book you'll then be recommended other
books based on purchases by people that
are also purchasing the same kind of
things that you purchase so okay so as
we have here a user that joins a
particular group or tribe as we call
them may also want to join tribe why
based on similar users however the issue
that we kind of have within six tribes
itself is that we don't have any
historical user data so therefore how do
we onboard users like brand new users
entirely okay so now let's look at
something content-based filtering so
this is more about projecting users to
an interest-based so here we'll project
the user to an interest space and hence
derive its tribe however then the issue
with any kind of startup that you
actually have is once again there's no
interest base so therefore we literally
have a problem of no data so how do we
find this interspace in order to define
it we need data but we had two problems
with data we didn't have any historical
data so we couldn't do collaborative
filtering and we didn't have any users
so we were ten people working in six
tribes and along with our early users we
had 100 peoples data to actually define
the the interspace but what data did we
have we had our users Facebook data and
this was these were posts and likes and
we also had our users phone data which
could be location in music so using this
data we had to create an interest space
take an interest space that we would
project our users in order to then make
the problem like transform the problem
into a similarity search problem so let
start with music now actually we don't
start with music we start with location
yes that is location so location you can
get it from three main sources you can
get it from the places you were tagged
in Facebook you can get it from your
phone photos you can also get it from
your GPS this is how location data looks
like when you take it from your iPhone
photo now intuitively good thing okay
let's find where our users are spending
most of their time in what are their
favorite places so you go about into the
latitude and longitude you would use
probably an external API like Google
Maps API a Foursquare API you could do
some reverse geocoding to find what
places are nearby those coordinates then
you would try to find the most frequent
places that you use users were spending
their time on and this would be the most
his favorite places can anyone guess
what was the most frequent location in
our user data boom
exactly and it wasn't it wasn't exactly
home it was all the places near your
home and the second most common location
was your work and it wasn't exactly work
it was all the place around your work so
all these data points didn't necessarily
mean that you did like these areas or
places it just meant that you worked and
lived there so there was a lot of noise
so this is our initial thing this is
what we end up doing it so what we did
is we took our entire users we've
reversed geocode every every location
that they were going to we found the
most popular ones like Hyde Park or
Shorty's these were quite common among
our users are 100 users and we
hard-coded it and we were planning to
automate that in the future when we were
actually would launch the app by doing
the same process in eventually having
some sort of heuristic or strategy to
find the most common locations in places
now the second dimension of our users
were music now again we want to find
what kind of musics our users were into
and what did we have we had our iPhone
music library so again the most obvious
thing to do to find out what kind of
music people like trees and would be to
actually go into their music
aggregate see what the common most
common artists that people were using
and see okay you're really into that and
that artists in order to actually then
much with other people that take the
same music
but it wasn't that easy first of all
because some songs you had in your
library weren't actually played it could
be part just it would just be part of
the album that was in your phone most
importantly some of these songs were not
played recently so you need to take into
account when was this song that was
present in the library left played and
it couldn't be recent because of two
reasons maybe you wouldn't using wood
you weren't using the music app on your
iPhone or because your music taste your
music taste changes over time and my
latest song was from high school for
instance so you don't want to
necessarily take into account five six
years time back thirdly the most popular
artists in our user base was u2 and this
was not because we really were are you
just really likely to it was because
Apple decided to push the u2 album to
every iPhone user this is what we ended
up doing don't take into account the
code is a little bit wrong in the decay
but we ended up decaying basically
taking into account the how long ago you
were actually listening to that song not
taking into account u2 and and taking
into account how many times you played
that song the more time you play that
song the more you like that song the
third dimensions we're using we're
Facebook Likes now again you can say in
order to figure out how you can use the
likes to actually see what kind of
interest your users have you could say
you have you will have to find out what
the like is about now hopefully Facebook
has a category for the likes that from
the pages you like but they're not
necessarily informative so for instance
everyone likes restaurants and cafes but
that doesn't necessarily say a lot about
you in some few cases around 20% did you
provide a category list which is a
little bit more refined but again
sometimes it's very generic as well and
let's not forget the fact that some of
the pages you like are not pages you are
actually interested in - he's just your
friend create the page then he forced
you to like that page because of some
reason so again to solve that problem we
actually took this category list the
more refined ones we selected the ones
that were more informative
created a hard rule before launching
again because we didn't have any users
or 5,000 likes as being a reasonably
enough threshold to actually filter out
all this friend page this you liked and
took around and took an estimate about
the interest that you're like conveyed
now another thing we could do in legs
actually to it was to use natural
language in the description of the like
and in the post of the leg which is
exactly what we did in post so I'm gonna
describe that process here now with your
posts you have a lot of data actually
that was our most informative piece of
data now the problem here again is that
some of the posts you have made in
facebook don't necessarily have a
specific meaning so for instance here it
doesn't necessarily mean you like Donald
Trump
it doesn't necessarily leader mean that
you don't like him we don't know we
didn't solve that problem that is hard
enough problem so we didn't solve that
we did though use the links when you did
post something with the link we did use
those links that were associated with an
article so we want to figure out what
sort of articles were you actually what
were the articles that we were sharing
in facebook we're talking about to do
that we use the wrapper again I guess an
external API in our case was prismatic
mainly but you could also use alchemy
API to extract the keywords from the
article the topics what are the articles
are talking about and then figure out
what is the user what are the topic that
is user is sharing again let me say that
some of these topics didn't necessarily
mean that the user liked the topics
because of the previous problem and but
a really important takeaway point here
with the api's was the following it was
really informative to use api is all
along and we did use api's a lot but
when we did launch using an api was not
a reasonable thing to do for two main
reasons first of all it was great for
explorations but when we actually
launched the problem was first of all
api is are expensive so you have to pay
money for them and it's okay when you're
doing it for 100 people but when you're
doing it for thousands of people it's
starting it's yourself you have to pay
the bill secondly it produces an
overhead so our pipeline was basically
when someone was signing up we had five
seconds to actually
first sophisticated recommendation about
with other users or other user groups
you would be interested in and the
network overhead basically was flowing
that process down so that why we needed
we did all these curated lists okay so
let's go on to making recommendations
without data is impossible or is it okay
so as Nick mentioned we had a very few
amount of users so we actually had 10
users for the first 4 months then we
launched and then we got our first
hundred except try so our dates was very
limited so therefore producing a
recommendation system with 10 users
isn't really very scalable so that's why
we had to deal with a lot of enrichment
like we just discussed now in terms of
our user document itself just to be
crystal clear as well this is Mickey
Mouse so this is exactly what Mickey
Mouse's document should look like so we
have things such as like the age the
gender places which is dealt with the
next extraction process using here using
any kind of other api's that we can find
as well as things like artists so
Mickey's very keen on Walt Disney right
now on top of that also interests so
things like a steamboat dog because he
owns Pluto concert composing theater so
we list basically your interests based
on your alchemy and based on prismatic
kind of api's that we're using all from
your post so that they retain relevance
ok so now let's move on to the concept
of a tribe now with a tribe we deal with
things such as like crafty cats the
actual name itself dealing with things
such as age in order to deal with
filtering out and thresholding we deal
with genders as well which is kind of
controversial one one that I wasn't keen
on the Accio kind of made us do it and
then we also dealt with the interested
in like location for hyper location so
things such as if you want more of a
community based tribe or whether or not
you want maybe like a London based only
kind of tribe or even like a country
based tribe that's predominately for
location as well as the concept of the
radius as well so now if we go on let's
think about how we make a recommendation
system so we're going to use something
similarity search and the way we kind of
do it is we look at it in three kind of
components we look at the original
analysis then the matching and then the
scoring and I'll just talk you through
each one so now if we look about
analyzing
so one of our primary focuses was to
actually use elasticsearch and this is
where elasticsearch really came into its
power so if anyone who's used it you can
change the mappings you can kind of
change the settings and you can tweak it
accordingly so that she returns really
precise search results however we're
using it here beyond search results so
maybe we'll add things such as synonyms
things like kon foodies clearly is
related to food but our tribe names
actually became really kind of quite
complex you no longer knew we're about
food or whether or not they're about
music so you use that in order to allow
kind of like searches based on interests
as well as that we use kind of the
normal kind of things such as stemming
and such as like standardizing the text
that was both given and indexed okay
moving on as well we get matching okay
so matching was kind of like a key part
in terms of building the recommendation
system so obviously we've only got ten
uses so you know we have to kind of like
use a naive best approach that we can so
what we did was is we did like a search
by a weighted vector using a boosting
ability according to your interests now
some of you who may be familiar with the
elastic search may wonder why we didn't
use more like this
well the issue with more like this is if
you give it an empty body it will return
to you lots of random documents
according to when they're inserted by it
won't actually give you relevant
documents according to interests so this
actually leads us on to a further
ability that we had to do which is the
concept of scoring now with regards to
scoring we looked at both age gender and
location and what you can actually do
with inelastic searches as and when you
get results back and at search time you
can kind of predetermine what kind of
score and what kind of metrics you want
to prioritize over others so therefore
you can say if something's like age
range for example is really important
and maybe you want kind of like a
hipstery Hoxton base tribe and therefore
you want to limit the age range from 18
to 25 etc so this was kind of concept
this is all written in groovy here and
then as I mentioned previously as well
gender you can do gender age tribes as I
said I don't agree of this at all
this actually got removed entirely as a
result basic returning bad results and
as a result of you know gender equality
right now so this was really unnecessary
for us and also in terms of locations so
what happens when a user simply doesn't
have any interests so once again we need
to have a fallback kind of method so our
fallback was really like losing at
location using location and really
trying to have understanding of
hypersensitive location tribes as well
as maybe tribes on like a country or
city level etc so these are all
integration as to how we can make a
recommendation system with very little
data ok now on the engineering side I'm
just going to briefly talk you through
the micro service the deployment and
improving but error handling and the
scalability so now if we go into my
crease ervis now as a data scientist
quite often you've probably all
experienced you will do something in
data science you'll pass on a python
script maybe pass on some other kind of
script and it will get embedded into
into your scarlet backends or whatever
kind of back-end you're using
usually pass it on to engineers but when
you're in a particularly small start-up
you simply don't have the privilege I
guess of doing that so we decided to do
it slightly different for many reasons
we wanted to iterate quickly and we
wanted to be able to make these changes
in production immediately so they'd hit
the app straightaway and how he did this
was having our app then having like our
Scala back-end and then we actually
provided a flask based science API as
micro service which dealt with all of
our data science requests things such as
like returning the tribes returning
another concept as well called social
DNA and then we would use things such as
like s3 for our raw data as well as like
elasticsearch as I said to do with the
transform data and to deal with the
actual matching itself so now this is
kind of like what our endpoint would
really look like so it was very much
about getting the tribes matching the
user ID and then returning the
particular score that we've calculated
by tweaking that elasticsearch now
deployment and improving so some of you
may have heard of circle CI now this was
actually really key for us because we
wanted to make sure that as we deploy to
production straightaway when we're
dealing with such a small kind of like
startup at the stage then we can ensure
that it's consistent ensure that it's
kind of quality code and it's not going
to break anything with regards to
production and with regards to the
backend so we use circle CI as our
continue
improvement and we also use things such
as like awf elastic beanstalk and s3
it's really hosts our micro service as
well as deal with both the raw data and
the transform data and then also
actually just to mention so the really
important thing for us was in a very
small start-up only 10 people dates for
the first four months was this killing
this kind of like feedback loop now as
most of you know you can get user
feedback maybe they dismiss something on
an app excetera but right now this is
pre-release to an app so how do we kind
of get this feedback so it did very much
involved showing people what tribes they
were matching to and saying to them what
is working what isn't working being able
to go to power friends and say you know
do you mind this trying out your data
can we show you whether or not it works
or not and we were constantly working on
this kind of like feedback approve and
iteration in order to improve matches
now this was really key so we used to
prep up data for use the testers to come
into our company test it out and them
and see kind of like what they think so
we could really retain the freshness
okay in terms of error handling so
something which I found really useful
particularly having a micro service is
actually using up B so if anyone's ever
used B the great advantage of this over
normal logging is you get to see what
the variables contain as and when it
goes through your code and when you find
an error so for example like if all of a
sudden we were finding a particular data
string was causing a massive error which
hopefully it wasn't but if it was we
could then go back and we could trace
back exactly what experience that users
had so this was a really great tool and
I really recommend to like people
looking at this in the future and then
scalability as I mentioned the advantage
of elasticsearch is really its ability
to scale it is primarily a search tool
but it can work very well with these
tweaks and these personalized mappings
as a recommendation system but it works
well at scale scaling so it meant like
if we were to get 100 million downloads
which we never quite got it means that
we didn't have an issue with regards to
that okay now going on to our lessons
learned what some we have 20 minutes so
I can
it's very very thank you son books
research time basically refers to don't
spend too much time on exploring things
you actually have to ship things and our
CEO business people you know how they
are wanted some deliverables always some
reason and so some books your research
time that makes past the expectations on
how much is it gonna take it's really
important sometimes and if you want your
sanity you start off with as much data
and adjustment that so this is the point
I was trying to convey like use external
IPs use as many resources you have but
also that's reality when you want to
deploy
they are both expensive and they are
both expensive in money and expensive in
time so use them to actually learn
quickly but then also spend some time to
actually deploy and explore an area that
is and can go to production and then the
other points are is really think about
real time versus batch so when we were
first doing with our research kind of
component we were very much dealing with
a very long slow process with regards to
like using lots of api's and what we
found was is we could deliver results
very quickly to users by cutting out
those api it's and then by using api is
in the background
so therefore when a user would first
join the app maybe their searches and
their matches weren't great but then as
they use the app like 30 seconds in i'd
say all of a sudden they would
dramatically improve but we made sure
that improvement was also continuous and
that improvement made sense to them also
don't make assumption so something which
we often did very early on into their
app was particularly with data and
having so few data we made assumptions
so we made an assumption for example
that everyone Ferrara ties music
actually turns out not everyone is
considering music as one of their main
interests so therefore why do we treat
it as a separate interest and we
actually have to treat it as a separate
interest do to do two business demands I
guess and it turns out that it made our
matches really bad however what we did
was is we found actual user feedback fed
that back into the app and hence we
removed the kind of musical aspects so I
think it's really important but
when you're working with a very small
amount of data and you're trying to
build a start-up like this okay now
let's go on to our Q&A time so has
anyone got any questions that I'd like
to ask whilst we're here okay so thanks
for the talk you mentioned a debugging
tool earlier can I just clarify what
that was
it's called o8 so op8 yeah I really
recommend it it's quite easy to
integrate into your app so it just takes
a up beat token and that's about it and
then I believe there's a flask library
as well to handle there's also an
application so basically you can learn
when your code fails before your CEO
does really important I get any more
questions
have you tried elasticsearch percolators
no I haven't actually that's an area
that I'm not familiar with okay yeah
what's this wondering because I think it
allows you to put in a query and get
back the best matches yes he referring
to more like this as a query that's one
very similar there were some problems
with the location and so because I mean
where the information was living and it
would be it would be a nice thing to
explore and we did explore it but there
was some complication with location that
it was like the location of the tribe
was actually living in elasticsearch so
he didn't have it in curie time to query
against it so it was it was a nice thing
we could have done if you know our CEO
wasn't care about location but yeah was
it the concept in regards to changing
the radius varies one yeah okay thank
you No
yeah hey did you do any explanations of
these recommendations do you ever get
users asking for explanations or did you
did you try out showing it to them
because it seems like you had a pretty
good understanding of your features so
you'd be able to say this is a location
recommendation or here's some people who
like the same artists as you the user
profile we actually give back some of
this interest based vectors so another
part of our work was to actually display
all this interest we thought you have so
that gave them some part of the
explanation could you could see 20 the
20 most relevant talks about your music
where you hang out like why are you
interested in you could actually see it
in your profile and figure out why you
were suggested to certain things now
when we were lucky enough how users
in-house then some people actually
wondered as Ruby mentioned about the
gender because gender for instance for
parenting was only for some reason again
business decision targeted in women and
a parent who was a male it happens I was
asking why he wasn't getting the
parenting tribe and this is when this is
when we have to change our algorithm
really so we too often took feedback so
as Nicholas said a man wanted to join a
parenting tribe and our CEO will be very
very disagreed with illness like I had a
very long argument basically said oh
let's make it woman's only tribe and I
was like no we're not gonna do that but
that's a long story that I should say
off camera feminism's probably a better
example guy any be female be aware of
oK we've got any more questions in the
audience
okay okay so I think the plan now is to
head to oh we have got another I know
you all want to download six tribes at
the moment don't cuz it doesn't exist
yeah but we can give you a hint it's
like to do with Jeremy Clarkson so you
can kind of imagine like what's become
fenestrae right yeah yeah of course it's
become Finnish tribe so you were saying
about the as you've got more data it
became more fun so how often do people
change tribes and did that often lead to
people saying oh hang on they've changed
tribe that don't want to be in this
tribe anymore and so in terms of
behavioral changes in terms of like
leaving etc we were using more about
when people were joining a particular
tribe to treat that like as a positive
kind of response terms of like living
tribes we weren't able to get to that
kind of stage in terms of behavior
aspects being back in we did get to a
stage of creating tribes so if your
tribe wasn't found then you could to
create accordingly as well as searching
on keywords which is kind of quite handy
you know startups run out of money
sometimes it's not good but if we had
them then yes the plan was to actually
then train models to learn from this
behavior because that after some point
we did have this sort of data because
because our using the app class we were
building a collaborative filtering
because I again we did have some users
having join some tribes so then the
problem became okay some people did come
and we don't know anything about them
but then we also have these people that
are in the app and we want to actually
recommend them new other tribes
according to the tribes they joined they
choose to join so that we actually
started developing in a collaborative
filtering algorithm using spark but we
went out of money okay we're both
actually we're both working freelance
right now
Greenland's okay I'm working for it so
get in touch with me okay so anyway that
will wrap up the top so thank you very
much for listening